l'aéroport de roissy s'agrandit et après
quatre ans de travaux à nouveau terminal
vient d'être inauguré ce matin
il permettra à l'aéroport charles de
gaulle d'accueillir chaque année
plusieurs millions de passagers
supplémentaires ce terminal sera
exclusivement occupé par air france-klm
guérini et jeff cinquième élément de
l'aérogare numéro deux le terminal f
une coque lumineuse impressionnante de
60 m de portée
accroché un élément central et qui vous
amène vers l'avion capacité de passage
de ce premier module 6 millions de
voyageurs 10 millions quand son jumeau
sera achevé en 99
c'est le dernier élément de l'aérogare 2
mis à la disposition d'air france pour
ses vols dit schengen vers l'europe
c'est un bâtiment qui est prêt à
accueillir des gens c'est un bâtiment
qui n'est pas fini tant que les gens
sont pas là ni en couleur ni en
mouvement ni il va tirer tout son
intérêt de justement des gens de leur
couleur leur mouvement et où c'est la
foule des aéroports très particulière
c'est pas la foule d'un stade c'est pas
la cool c'est pas une foule qui est
concentré sur un objet ce sont des gens
qui vont tous prendre un avion et chacun
le leur un qui ne se parlent pas qu'ils
se croisent qui se côtoient c'est la
ville en fait les installations
actuelles de roissy était saturé avec 35
millions de personnes c'est dire que
cette livraison soulage aéroports de
paris la compagnie nationale après les
péripéties passer de leur développement
enfin les autorités françaises le
gouvernement les riverains tous les
partenaires du transport aérien sont
maintenant convaincus qu'on ne peut plus
travailler comme avant et que les
contraintes environnementales c'est à
dire le respect de l'environnement fait
partie du développement
c'est donc une étape nouvelle c'est un
nouveau système de prise en compte d'un
équilibre entre l'environnement et le
développement de ce sahara l'emploi et
l'économie
quand les deux dernières pistes seront
mises en service en 99 et 2001
la plateforme aéroportuaire d'île de
france sera la deuxième en europe après
londres